You know, it's funny.
If you look at everything that Google does
for the iPhone and the iPad,
we really do a lot.
But for some reason, people don't think of
us as an iOS company,
and I don't know why that is.
Oh... Yeah, right.
But the fact of the matter is we have
a whole bunch of crazy smart engineers
that are building dozens of apps
for iOS devices.
And we have SDKs available for everything,
from maps, to analytics, to games,
that you could use to power your own app.
OK guys, seriously, is there
nowhere else we could film?
Like, anywhere?
But you know,
maybe some of that's on us.
Maybe we need to do a better job
of reaching out to this community.
And so that's why we're creating
this series of videos,
just for you iOS developers.
We'll be telling folks about new libraries
we're releasing for iOS,
and sharing some tips
from our very own engineers.
So come join us right here on Route 85,
our brand new show for iOS developers.
Because when you think iOS,
think Goo... oh, come on! Really?
Can... You know what?
Forget it! Forget it! I quit!
You guys, you film your own promo!
I'm done here!
This is ridiculous!
This is so (bleep) ridiculous!
I can't find one (bleep) place
in this whole campus
where I can film one stupid commercial!
Route 85, the way to go for iOS developers.
Coming soon to the Google Developers
YouTube channel.